so all this time the anti-abortion  republicans are saying don't abort  adopt find people to adopt there's so  many people to adopt your kids and then  now marjorie taylor green says  non-biological parents are bad they're  dangerous the idea that mom and dad  together not not fake mom and fake dad  but biological mom and biological dad  when you adopt a kid it's not your  biological kid with some exceptions  where one parent adopts the child of the  other of their partner or whatever the  case may be so abortion's bad  and adoption is bad so do they even  really care about any of this stuff or  is it all just virtue signal the  signaling to their radical right  followers i think you know the answer